so the timeline here is important in  understanding this relationship between  radagon and ranala was radagon already  also America when he came to the lands  between and battled against ranala his  arrival on a great golden host suggests  that he was already a part of the golden  order was he at this point just split  from his body with America in order to  battle against opposing factions of the  golden order one Theory suggests that  America knowingly took control of  radagon started a consortship with  ranala just to in the end leave her to  break her heart ranala when we meet her  in game is obviously not in her normal  frame of mind if America intended for  this to happen where Ronaldo loses her  sanity after her heart is broken it  clearly worked in regards to ranala no  longer being a threat against the golden  order